ORISTAR cung cấp nhôm đồng inox đủ dài kích thước, cắt theo yêu cầu chỉ từ 1 tấm.
Trong sản xuất công nghiệp, vật liệu không chỉ cần đúng mát, mà còn phải đúng dạng, đúng
kích thước và đúng quy cách để phù hợp với từng công đoạn sản xuất.
Tại ORISTAR, nhôm đồng và thép được cung ứng đa dạng về chủng loại, dạng vật liệu và kích
thước, đáp ứng từ nhu cầu vật liệu tiêu chuẩn đến yêu cầu gia công cụ thể.
Với dạng tấm, ORISTAR cung cấp đa dạng quy cách, từ chiều dày 1-600mm, chiều rộng 11-600mm
và chiều dài lên đến 6mm.
Với kích thước và dung sai được kiểm soát theo tiêu chuẩn ORISTAR hoặc là yêu cầu kỹ thuật
của khách hàng.
Với sẻ cuộn, ORISTAR ra công theo yêu cầu về khổ rộng, chiều dài, khối lượng, chất lượng
theo yêu cầu.
Kiểm soát tốt dung sai độ lượng, ba via khổ xẻ, đảm bảo bề mặt đẹp, đóng gói và bảo quản
trong môi trường kiểm soát nhiệt độ cùng độ ẩm tiêu chuẩn.
Gia công phay chính xác 4-6 mặt, đảm bảo độ vuông góc, độ phẳng, kiểm soát ba via, đảm bảo
độ ổn định của sản phẩm sau gia công.
Phên cạnh gia công cơ khí, ORISTAR còn xử lý nhiệt kim loại giúp tăng độ cứng, ổn định cơ
tính, giảm ứng suất dư, đảm bảo chất lượng và độ bền sản phẩm sau xử lý.
Xử lý bề mặt kim loại bằng phương pháp thấm ni tơ chân không, giúp tăng độ cứng bề mặt, cải
thiện khả năng chống mài mòn, nâng cao tuổi thọ chi tiết, hạn chế biến dạng, từ một tấm
đến số lượng lớn, từ cung ứng vật liệu đến gia công hoàn thiện.
ORISTAR đáp ứng theo từng mạc vật liệu, quy cách và tiêu chuẩn kỹ thuật của từng đơn hàng.
Nếu doanh nghiệp bạn đang cần mua hay gia công kim loại theo yêu cầu, liên hệ ngay hotline
0988 750 686 để nhận tư vấn.